did you see the Jim Carrey documentary
which one I saw one where he did the men
on the moon he talked about that one
yeah and he type ritty sure he talks
about his dad I think his dad was he did
talk about his dad yeah I remember his
dad so his dad gave up his dreams to be
a comedian in the Jim Carrey documentary
and he did the 9 to 5 and then the 9 to
5 that was the steady job laid him off
so he realized at that point that there
was no safe bet and that is true man
it's completely true I see that all the
time with people that they really hold
on to their nine-to-five job but
nothing's guaranteed nothing's
guaranteed so it's like you gotta take
chances you got it you know that but
that's life people you know you got to
make mistakes too and that's why a lot
of people I know so many filmmakers that
aren't willing to do their first feature
because they're too scared to make a
mistake you know it's like no you got to
make it and if you fail you fail or if
you make a movie that's not the best you
can do great learn from it and make
another film but I know more than one
director that is phenomenal that has
never done a feature you know and I've
known them for 10 years you know do you
think it's the money aspect I could see
why that would be scary but what do you
think it is I think people have all
kinds of excuses you know I mean I think
money is kind of usually the number one
excuse I don't have enough money or I
can't get enough money to make the the
feature but I mean what are you doing to
try to get the money you know there's
that aspect a lot of them go I don't
have the right script and I'm not a
script writer you know a lot of that
kind of stuff and that's one of the
reasons that while I got wasted it was
like Seth my writing partner seth Himes
basically he wrote a script and he came
to me and I didn't really particularly
like it I liked the first 20 pages and I
was like the first 20 pages was slightly
similar to while he got wasted and I was
like I thought I really thought the
movie was gonna go in this direction
because in the first three pages it's
about three guys that accidentally
killed somebody and then the movie will
win a totally different direction and I
was like I really thought you were gonna
kind of revamp weekend at Bernie's and
put hangover together and kind of do
this like new kind of comedy movie
because that's what we ended up doing
and he was like no and after he was
heartbroken for a while because I
my honest opinion he came back and was
like well let's write the idea that you
have and so that was like 2014 and so we
were living together at the time we were
roommates and I laid out the whole movie
in one night with him and I came up with
the structure of it and then he didn't
we didn't end up writing it he ended up
moving out later and then like six
months later he came back and he wrote a
first draft and like a day or two
because he's a very fast writer and
there was like one scene in the first
draft which was the drive-thru scene in
the movie that was phenomenal and which
was great because I could literally he
did my outline though so it had the
correct outline but it just wasn't as
good as it needed to be yet but it was
nice because I always try to stick on
the positive because any artist is very
sensitive usually and so I was like
listen this is phenomenal but the
drive-thru scene is amazing and the
whole movie needs to be as good as the
drive-thru scene so we need to do
rewrites so then we did then we'd ended
up doing rewrites for about eight or
nine months to a year on the script and
and getting it to where we thought it
was strong and then we ended up trying
to get you know I had enough connections
in Hollywood that I was trying to send
it to anybody that could help me make it
at the time which is where mostly every
filmmaker ends up dying because they're
trying to hand their project to somebody
else to help make it and that's usually
fallen on dead ears so we did that and
there was one studios talking about
making it and some other stuff it was
just talk and eventually I said you know
what we can't keep doing this I got I
let's just do it ourselves
you know so we ended up raising the
money ourselves selling units to the
movie for a certain dollar amount you
owned a percentage of the movie and I
was gonna sell units to anybody I could
sell units to I sold them to doctors I
sold them to dentists I sold them to
somebody in France I sold them to
somebody in Mississippi I sell them
anywhere I could sell them and talk to
people and you know talking to people
and convincing them and your check is
never easy but I always tell people I'm
one of the luckiest people you ever meet
and
people seem to like me and trust me so
I'm lucky in that aspect but I delivered
I delivered the movie like I promised I
would so we raised the money took like a
year maybe a year and a half to raise
the money some not all the money we
wanted to but 70 grand
well 70 grand yes but Seth my partner
actually was coming up with 40 of that
probably so we only raised like 30 of it
and unfortunately chef was in a bad
business deal and I actually did not
know that so I was like we have the 70
grand we can start so I did all the
casting in the movie already I found all
the locations we found I found 38
locations for free in Los Angeles
it's like unheard of right how did you
do that meeting well we have
drive-throughs we have grocery stores we
have fast-food restaurants we have
nightclubs it took time you know and I
didn't want to put dates down for the
film until I found locations and found
all my actors I did not want to have a
date because I was working every day on
it anyway it was I didn't need a time to
like push me I was working on it every
day so I didn't put a date down for the
film yet but I would every location we
needed I would go out there and it was a
fast-food restaurant I'd walk into every
fast-food restaurant I could and be like
hey can we use this space to shoot you
know I can I speak to the manager and
talk to them
Cheng's basically would all turn me down
it's a corporate decision so I learned
very quickly I need to find mom-and-pop
places mom-and-pop grocery stores mom
about fast food places basically I need
to be able to talk to the person that's
making the decision and not have a
million you know lines to get to who I
need to talk to and it was just
convincing people with passion really
and it was my first feature my butt was
on the line and I think they saw how
much excitement I had and a lot of
people just agreed to help me and and
then sometimes it was a connection
through somebody else and you know the
grocery store was a connection through
Seth it was a friend of his from college
who knew somebody who owned a grocery
store and they gave us permission to
shoot there and then we went there on
the day and they didn't know who we were
then somebody didn't even tell him but
they saw the camera in the crew and they
were excited and they ended up letting
her shoot there I don't even know if we
need to permission to shoot there
because they didn't know who we were and
we shot the grocery store when it was
open so it was like but my actors were
joking and that we have a 35 minute
documentary on YouTube actually people
can type in wall-e got wasted behind the
scenes and it'll pop right up as a 35
minute a little documentary about how we
made the film but one of the actors in
the documentary is like live theatre you
know because there's homeless people
walking by there's regular people
walking by in the middle of the shot
when we're shooting you know but we made
it work you know and yeah so just
convincing every location to let us
shoot there and some of these locations
would back out the day before because it
would be like like the fast-food
restaurant was like I need to come there
tomorrow night beach after he said oh
you come after your clothes
we closes at 10:00 I said okay he said
well how long you need to be here he's
thinking I need to be there like an hour
you know no we need to shoot until the
Sun comes up like I need as much time as
possible so normally we'll try to shoot
12 hours but I have the Sun so we'll
shoot from 10 p.m. to a 5 a.m. and he's
like oh I have to stay ultra 5 hey
heaven like Hugh mmediately was like I
don't want to do this anymore and I was
like listen you you can't bail on me
like if you bail on me I have nothing
I'm completely screwed so I would
convince him to stay basically and
that's that would happen a lot so you
know rewind all the way back to Seth
getting that money stolen from him I
that happened so I thought we were
shooting the movie for 70 grand and and
to rewind Seth had a visit Seth was
gonna put in 40 grand stole that 40
grand so he didn't know until the first
day of shooting so basically the whole
first day of shooting you see photos and
videos of him and he's you could see
he's like having a nervous breakdown
it's like eyes like half open and you
know because he has to us to tell me
that he lost all that money and so we
have our first day of shooting and we
finally get back because he moved back
into my apartment
to shoot the movie and he comes into my
room after like 14 hours of shooting of
the day and he goes he just completely
like is destroyed and he's like I lost
all the money we haven't shut the movie
down and I was like SAS I got to tell
you there's nothing in the world that
can stop me from shooting this movie at
this point like no we're not gonna stop
I used a 30 grand and we'll put the rest
on credit cards me and you will open
credit cards I'm gonna finish the movie
we'll put everything we possibly can on
credit cards but we will not stop the
movie and here in my room is like we're
gonna shut down the movie I'm gonna move
from away from Los Angeles and I'm done
with this dream I'm never gonna do it
again and I was like no you're gonna
finish your dreams and forget it drive
forward and I wouldn't let him quit I
was like we have to do this and so
that's what we did we put the rest of
the movie on a 40 grand or something on
credit cards and 30 grand we used to pay
the crew and the people we needed to pay
but and we finished it so
you